okay why don't we go ahead and get
started this is you know I missed last
week but this is just great to see I
think back you saw me taking some
pictures of it no I you know we've been
wondering you know we've been hoping to
kind of increase attendance and there's
an obvious cause and effect here and I'm
actually really glad we've done this you
know a few years ago the OHSU budget was
tight they were encouraging departments
not to spend money on frivolous things
like food at conferences but clearly
this is worth it anyways um however a
couple a couple things because it's so
crowded in here this is some feedback I
got last week that because there's so
many people in here you might be tempted
to lean over and say something to
someone next to you and when multiple
people do that the noise level starts to
rise so please be respectful of the
speaker I was also asked that people
spend too much time checking whatever
they're checking on their device in
front of them I would I would be
hypocritical if I said to you don't do
that at all because I will probably peek
down to my device once or twice during
the talk but just don't overdo it and
give the respect that our speaker
deserves and speaking of our speaker all
of you probably all of you know dr.
David door who's a member of our faculty
indie mice he's actually vice chair of
clinical informatics and for the last
year or so I don't know the exact amount
has also taken on a new role here at
OHSU as chief research informatics
officer which is not only great for him
but it's actually great for the
university to have someone in that role
who's really focused on informatics
issues in research and in fact that's
the topic of his talk today so as I
always do give a little bit of
biographical information dr. door X he
grew up in the
Portland area he went off to college in
medical school at Washington University
he then came to OHSU to do his internal
medicine residency actually that's when
I first met him and he expressed an
interest in informatics we were hoping
he would stay on and be an NLM fellow
but he got lured away to the University
of Utah where he did an informatics
fellowship there a very wonderful
excellent program and then he as he was
finishing that came back and joined our
faculty and he's worked his way up
through the ranks professor and vice
chair and cRIO so I will turn it over to
David yeah thank you so in the beginning
of this talk I actually talked about
what a cRIO does which is different
there's actually some papers around it
but don't worry if you've never heard of
this role it's actually not that well
it's increasingly common but wasn't that
common five years ago instance sort of
people have recognized using data
information and knowledge and research
has gotten incredibly complex and yet is
necessary for most people there do
research and so that's why we have that
role I'm actually trained as an
internist so I'm a physician by training
and many people in these roles actually
at phd's because there's a whole set of
issues around sort of the basic science
of data so people who use very large
data sets that are often freely
available like some genomic information
that's sort of protected in different
ways and some other sort of large-scale
data sets we I deal with that too but
I'm not going to talk about it today we
have we know of a number of issues
related to managing and and deal with
that kind of data here but I'm mainly
going to talk about some of the some of
the clinical the sort of translational
aspects of the research and specifically
about there's a huge transformation
going on in terms of trying to make
things more available more interoperable
for research for
innovation not just at OHSU but across
the country and so I'm gonna sort of
talk about that and then reflect on what
we're trying to do here at HQ we
actually just received word a month or
so ago two months ago that in the
strategic planning process that I hope
some of you participated in we have a
research informatics funded effort
that's supposed to go over the next five
years to 2025 that allude to so we're
very excited about that and it's just
the right time to get your input so I
hope that you sort of talk to me about
your issues as well and my contact
informations here so what do I do in
this role it's actually half my time the
rest of time I do research actually and
do clinical care but as as creo I really
try and figure out for in a research
informatics perspective what are we
missing what would help researchers and
innovators at OHSU do their jobs better
in regards to data information and
knowledge and then I try and pull that
together into some kind of vision always
sort of evolving that vision or at least
how we're approaching that vision but
this is sort of the vision we came up
with and I'll talk very specifically
about these so the first one is about
OHSU becoming a learning organization
and a learning health system as well as
part of that and I'll talk very
specifically what that means but it
means we use data and analyze it and
think about it and then do tests of
change in our every day carry their
everyday work here so and there's some
great examples of that
we also many of you focus on analytics
or data science sort of the really hard
core computational stuff and that we
have many strengths in that but we're
not really seeing nationally as a
consistent leader it's more episodic how
could we become that leader and then
what can we do to sort of enhance the
services that are available to people
here doing research around information
technology and then also finally and
maybe in some ways most important
the research now requires much more
collaboration and sharing and there's a
natural tension between protected health
information or restricted information
and making data more available open
making what we do sharing it with with
others and so my goal is to sort of make
things more findable accessible
interoperable and reusable through
things like licensing and and better
agreements for people so that that we
know and and I have many partners in
this that I won't name all of them but
work together to basically manage this
so I sort of sit one thing about me is I
I don't really manage a whole group I
just work with lots of people I actually
manage my research group I guess but I
work with lots of people so there are
many touch points and I work really hard
to try and have really good
relationships with them and so if you
come to me and say how do I get
something like X done that's something
that I really am focused on here
actually is understanding the solutions
to challenging problems in research so
you know I work a lot with oaktree we
have some oak tree representatives here
like Rob and Amy work at the library
that is not on here I'm sorry about that
that's Chris and Robin and I work of
course with fellows come and rotate with
me as well as more of the health system
side that I try and work with them as
they're doing innovation and then I work
externally so there's lots of
relationships we have with organizations
and entities there's lots going on with
U of OU and OSU and PSU as well as with
National Labs and with people across the
country and so I try and build those
more strongly because it's so crucial to
do research my research is closely
aligned with some of the examples that
I'll give you but we focus on how we can
use data information and knowledge to
transform health for especially
vulnerable populations what do I mean by
that populations that maybe aren't
currently well served by our society or
healthcare system so we focus on social
determinants of health we focus on
complex illness it
illness identification of risk and then
how we can address that better in the
care we deliver and improve outcomes for
for folks so we we do a lot of that I
won't talk much about that here but come
and talk to me so what is evolving sort
of nationally and here around especially
data first that's what I'm gonna focus
on and then I'll talk about algorithms
and then I'll talk about learning
organization so as I said research
really has transformed in its
requirement to have data compared to so
I sit on a couple of study sections for
reviews and compared to when I sort of
started doing research the expectation
that people will present data analyses
in their in their work has just grown it
is an expectation that you will have
some prior data in your larger grants
everywhere and more data it's expected
that you'll have access to it and but
getting access to that data can be
challenging because of what I've talked
about so we really have to think about
how we govern because there are many
laws like HIPAA and actually other ones
that control how we can release data but
there are ways to get access to it so I
helped with that and we're actually
starting up a research data Governance
Committee which never has an existed
here for a while to manage this we also
think a lot about how the EHR data can
facilitate research because that's the
other thing people who submit to the NIH
frequently if it has a clinical and
translational component how do you
access to your EHR data how can you use
it we have research data warehouse here
that gets that data and transforms it
and makes it available with lots of
services for you and so how can we
continue to offer those up and make it
experience of doing that better we also
have ways that you can leverage our EHR
to do your research you can build things
within it or you can interface using
tools we also have to bring some data
together how can we better integrate
data and make it available for people
and then how can we share and
collaborate
so give you some examples of the kinds
of data that many people want to get
access to now and in each of these I
list this little like in the top on PA
1707 seven that is a very specific call
that requires this kind of research data
from the NIH so if you want to just
enter those into a search browser you
will find that call and say oh why do we
need patient reported outcomes these are
outcomes that are specifically the
perception of people pain their degree
of symptoms related to a particular
illness their overall quality of life
and those are really important outcomes
that we don't collect and clinical care
yet are incredibly important to
understanding how we're doing and to run
studies on how we can improve so that's
a kind of data we don't have ready
access to how can we work on that social
and behavioral data I think you all know
have heard about health-related social
needs or social determinants of health
are a huge predictor of our health over
time yet we don't often collect these or
have these available at the individual
level and we're working on ways to doing
that as well as we often don't know if
you're studying people in the health
system if you're extracting that data
we're missing lots of their data we
don't know their outcomes because if
they were here and then they went
somewhere else they passed away there or
they had a significant event there we
don't have that data necessarily and so
how can we help researchers have more
complete data sets when they're studying
that so there has been a huge number of
efforts to manage this and bring
together in more standard ways and make
accessible across institutions data that
addressed these and and I want to
encourage you to go and look at these
and figure figure out if any of them
relate to them with the caveat that the
data quality the queer use for your
research for this data really needs to
be tested before you use it but I'll
give you some examples to really pull
this in and and some new ways to access
that data
as well so there are now all these
extremely large databases that are
federated meaning they're not stored in
one place but there are ways to get
access to large amounts of that data
through various ways so sentinel and
mini sentinel which comes actually out
of the fda which sort of regulates our
drugs and trials now has a huge number
of people who submit data on effects of
medications and that's used in lots of
studies including real world data
evidence for new trials the FDA is
exploring an incredibly fun area that
they're doing that's an almost 200
million people's data is in that pakore
net which is actually a patient-centered
outcomes focused network has about 65
million patients we have one in the
Portland metropolitan area that we
participate in called advance and these
are to do trials of people with people
actively participating and setting up
the trial and managing that to
understand population level outcomes
accrual the clinical trials which is
more focused on clinical and
translational science award ease like
our own oak tree here has about 40
million people and we participate in
that you can actually go on the website
I'll show later and sort of see how that
works if your clinical trial list and
then the one I'll talk most about which
has roughly about 500 million people's
data mapped into this data model is
called uma and the organization that
sort of manages is Odyssey and I'll show
you some examples so here's here's them
we don't actually I I've actually done a
mini OMA instance but we this is not
sort of ATO HQ but this is actually
accessible they have de-identified data
sets that you can actually use and there
are there are hundreds of collaborators
there's a central sort of forum that
they all sort of participate on
and they basically come from lots of
different places historically this is
much more pharmaceutical industry focus
but it's it's really been transformed
and I'll show you what they can do with
this so this is on a study that's a
subset of the total 240 million patients
that basically subsetted that type 2
diabetes' t 2 DM and then looked at what
drugs they were being treated with both
alone only drug and then with two or
more drugs overall in the Sunburst plot
that's from the and my references it on
here sorry it's from oops AK from the
PNAS and basically he looked at this and
if you do cut work in this area this is
amazing to understand what's happening
with patients well they also have
outcomes for patients and sorry that's a
little bit small but I use this to train
residents because we had a new diabetes
medve sodium glucose linked transporters
and there were some trials that said hey
I think these these seem to improve not
just diabetes outcomes but also
cardiovascular outcomes like congestive
heart failure and then they took five
large database basis mapped a new mop
and they ran cohort trials and a
retrospective cohort trial comparing
people who'd be given that drug with
similar people with similar conditions
and other treatments with those who
hadn't and said in fact yes the rate of
congestive heart failure for all those
patients is much lower so with we can do
these kinds of studies much more
effectively using this kind of tool they
did this not only in type-2 diabetes but
hypertension and depression and so if
you have an interest in this area then
these are great ways to sort of test out
some initial hypotheses we have a new
high blood pressure study so
hypertension is particularly interesting
to us and one thing we see when we look
at the guidelines is there's not a lot
of comparisons against individual drug
classes for how they help with high
blood pressure avoiding the bad outcomes
like
heart attack and stroke so here is us as
a something from jorpe seconds well the
legend study where he said look the RCTs
really don't do these pairwise
comparisons but with us we can actually
show that there's some improvements in
outcomes with certain classes of these
medications like ACE inhibitors or
angiotensin receptor blockers over other
other classes of medications and we can
start to test these over all so this
kind of model is amazing for doing some
clinical research it does have its
caveats though and so you know here we
said you know our thiazide is really
better than ACE inhibitors is probably
not physiologically but something's
probably different about those patients
there might be a selection bias there so
that kind of data is more available than
ever and under a big piece of
legislation that came up the 21st
century Secours Act we're trying to make
data from EHRs against all these models
this is a slide from the Center for data
to health the CD to H many of you
participate in that that basically says
how can we make the data exchangeable so
we can act on it no matter where it
comes from it's stored in many different
formats right now and it can't easily be
exchanged and so we're doing this in
part through fire which is fast
healthcare interoperable resources and
under this legislation it basically says
you have to open up your data to these
kinds of application programming
interfaces via fire api's and make it
available to patients at the very least
with no extra effort means that can't be
charged for it in general and then that
standardization also transfers over to
many research activities as well because
now we can set up applications that ask
many different sites for their data once
they agree to send it pull it all
together and do these kinds of large
studies much more easily in the future
so we are exploring that here in a
number of ways we have turned on our
patient patient fire
we have a couple of applications but
many sites are already sort of on route
to doing this because it's required so
at OHSU what are we doing around this
we're testing piloting not yet available
for widespread consumption oh no this
one is actually available call a tool
called clinical pipe and the the use
here is to basically if you're running a
study with lots of sites the sponsor of
the study can say use this tool and then
we'll set it up and then it will send
the EHR data out to this and every time
you go in to look at it it will sort of
tell you about all your study
participants and here's all the data we
have on them and then you can approve
that and send it off to the trial so
compared to hours and hours of searching
through the chart and checking to see if
new data has come in or getting reports
episodically now you can sort of do it
automatically and a similar tool through
our institutional research survey
application called redcap is piloting
this in a couple different ways I
highlight one called clinical data pool
where you set up a survey and then you
connect it specific data elements to to
the patient's records and then it pulls
the data over time for your studies it's
kind of an amazing concept for those of
you do clinical work and we've been
testing it Jen one of the clinical
informatics fellows who sort of did a
test with it to see how it's working so
we're sort of in the piloting stage so
we sort of welcomed more people to help
us understand it the real problem with
that data is now you could potentially
just set up your connections to
everywhere pull all the data out but
you're not really sure what you're
getting still so here's a study we did
and Nicole Weiss cough I should say
generated this complex looking thing but
EHR data is captured largely for billing
and documentation purposes it's not
captured for research so the precision
doesn't always match the need and what's
more complex is here we queried about 18
common chronic conditions that might be
important to people and we said
we looked we had vetted and approved of
alle dated sets of icd-9 and tin codes
for diagnoses and then we went into the
charts for these and said how often are
these really backed up by the formal
diagnosis of this illness and we found
first off about 30 percent no evidence
that this diagnosis really was in this
patient chart had been done for billing
or it was just sort of a piece of data
that had no additional backup so not
good enough for read most research
purposes and then we found you can find
these diagnoses in a probabilistic the
patient level and encounters where they
see a particular provider in their
medical history where somebody might
have mentioned this or put a code in you
could do phenotypic rules like for
diabetes if they have an a1c above a
level and where you can put them all
together and we actually found in
general the best for finding the most
diagnoses was was just combining them
all for sensitivity but very poor
specificity so really if you're thinking
about that for your own work you really
need to be testing that and Nicole Weiss
cough is our local expert in data
quality she has a cake grant in it she
can tell you about this in general so
what are we planning to do to get make
it easier for you to get access to this
data
well we're exploring using different
techniques to getting this data and I'll
tell you very explicitly for patient
reported outcomes this is actually a big
institutional need the health system
needs this data for a lot of the things
they do so we're convening a big group
to basically code and make this data
available and then we'll publish the way
that you can get access to this data
about how people are doing over time
including getting directly from the
patient's themselves which is in crucial
overall for social and behavioral data
we did some studies and using natural
language programming my team Matt and
others participated in that to
understand how we could get that at the
individual level
pretty good precision on that actually
about 0.9 for most of the concepts using
a relatively straightforward approach
and then we're trying to get access to
additional data
through the strategic planning to
enhance what we have so it's more
reliable and useful for research and
here's we wrote a grant related to that
that we're we're gonna be submitting in
the next couple months to basically
highlight how we can add this data to
understand people's health outcomes over
over time so we also do this work
ourselves so here's what we do and we
have a tactic leader here Rob and in one
of these two we're transforming our
research data warehouse to basically
plan to get this data in here to do
these just the kind of things I
described as well as improving our high
performance computing environment and we
also are working for basic science
building a research data network that
allows people with high throughput high
volume non-restricted data to move it
more easily so which is already funded
and led by mandy terrell as of right now
so we're working on this we'll take data
that you'd like to integrate or problems
use cases come and tell us about it
because it's just the right time so
moving on this one's gonna be a little
bit easier for you because I presented
it to people who didn't know about much
about analytics initially but I thought
it'd be useful to understand that so in
healthcare in general and in pursuit of
health we're using a lot more analytics
we're using a lot more artificial
intelligence and other four specific
machine learning and techniques to try
and understand how we can provide better
care how we can understand speak over
time many of you do this how we can
predict illness and we need to really
think about when we're doing this how we
bring the right data together how we
test it and the reusable available tools
and then how we show it to people
because it's hard sometimes for people
to understand this and in fact OHSU as a
statement on artificial intelligence
augmented intelligence where we're like
if people can't understand how it got
there then that's a much higher bar
for presenting a prediction to
clinicians and we need to really think
hard about how we do that or patients
for those of you who are for those of us
who are not heavily into sort of
computation and the number of analytic
techniques that this is from a specific
domain but I thought it was really
useful is just daunting the number of
terms here for machine learning
algorithms that approaches is really
hard for people to understand yet every
day now health systems get approached by
a I companies that promise to do
something amazing for them how do we
sort that through and how do we create
really good ones because there's some
problems so give you some examples of
where this is going forward fast so
imaging now in imaging especially deep
learning convolutional neural networks
have a number of instances where they
can at least do as well as humans and
diagnosing disease so here are chest
x-rays where it basically took a number
of diagnoses from chest x-ray including
normal and compared it they compared it
against a set of radiologists for f
measure and the average of precision and
recall for how well it got the right
ones true dat true positives and true
negatives and basically it performs
slightly better than the average overall
although they're not statistically
significantly better for this algorithm
now this is a really complicated neural
network 121 layers so it's not easy to
implement but it's sort of amazing to us
in the field as well we have people here
that work on this problem mike chang
here it was leading an effort to do this
for images for retinopathy of
prematurity for when you're premature as
a baby you have a risk of having a
particular syndrome where you have low
can have low vision through your life if
it's not appropriately treated and
diagnosed it's a difficult problem to
treat and they used a similar approach
to both segments and classify through
convolutional neural networks images and
vessel maps to predict whether they were
definitely had retinopathy of
prematurity or
sort of this in-between state and so
once again they did slightly better
maybe not sophistica significantly
better than experts at least comparable
using this kind of technique so this is
like hugely important in part because
the ophthalmologists who can do this
aren't always so easy to find and so if
you can pre screen the images with an
algorithm we also at OHSU are really
interested in exploring this so we're
working on a number of prediction rules
not just in imaging but we use this to
risk stratify people who come here for
primary care is required by law for
something we do here and we try and
improve our algorithms all the time to
better match work so we're doing
research in that as well for
chemotherapy dosing we just submitted an
application to pakora the
patient-centered outcomes Research
Institute on outcomes using lean muscle
mass derived from CT scan images by
algorithm to dose chemotherapy almost
always a little bit lower than using
body surface area or body mass index
which has is usually higher and yet the
chemotherapy drugs are really determined
in part their effectiveness and
potential harm are determined by how
much lean muscle mass you have so we've
never had good indices of these so we're
trying to develop a way to automatically
generate that at all our patients and
then run a trial see if we could do that
if we're funded so Dan marks and Charlie
Lopez are the pis of that if you know
them we also have that group that's
doing this Peter graven operationally
and then of course we have biostatistics
with an oaktree
a core as well as a computational
faculty we also are very aware of the
bias that exists in the algorithms so
this is the paper from science that if
you have not seen I would highly
recommend you read and in this in the
study which is really good there's a
common algorithm that tries to predict
who will be the top 3% of overall cost
and utilization in the next year
got pretty good metrics around it's it's
performance at UCSF
at other places they use us to determine
who will get extra resources to try and
mitigate those risk makes sense they
found that in at ucsf for their
african-american patients they had worse
outcomes but we're not in this top 3%
because they couldn't get access to
healthcare to generate those costs and
utilization because the health system
itself had kind of a bias they didn't
have as good access and so this
algorithm was basically biased against
them in a way and not including them in
this in this work and they raised this
flag and it's generated a lot of
discussion including because we do
primary care risk stratification here a
big discussion about are we worsening
equity and I think that's incredibly
important the National Library of
Medicine also has a grant for
methodologies a notice for methodologies
and addressing this and I think if
you're interested in this area I think
Nicole Weisskopf also is submitting
something around that or you could talk
to us incredibly important so all right
so then finally learning health systems
how can we sort of understand everyday
the care we deliver and the health of
our populations that we serve and
improve it so this is really from Chuck
Friedman who has long been at Michigan
of infirmity ssin of note who really
said you know we should be using our
data all the time to generate new
knowledge and understanding and we
should put that knowledge into practice
and measure it so we should see how
we're performing compared to evidence so
we have the EPC here that does this and
it's really interested in closing this
loop and then look at that performance
and and constantly be measuring how
could we be improved what are we missing
overall and in a way this sort of takes
operations and brings them more closely
to research and let me give you an
example of a place that does this well
this is I think this was an informatics
fellow dr. self at Vanderbilt basically
ran this huge trial two trials actually
one in the IDI which is this one here
the emergency department one in the ICU
to say okay if you're a non-critical
adult in the IDI and you need fluid
should we give you normal saline or
which
we give you balanced crystalloids that
sort of match your current electrolyte
mix and they basically use the EHR and
every month switched to different
default for what they recommended by two
clinicians giving these fluids and after
they enrolled 13,000 patients in this
trial over the time period through this
opt-out default they said they found out
yeah balance crystalloids better about
1% better outcomes in adverse kidney
events so kidney injuries within 30 days
and so they said this is the new
standard of care these are amazing
transformative kinds of things you can
do with good that randomization by time
is a very good way to look at this
because it sort of evens out over time
and the recruitment of 13,000 patients
is amazing like to do that in a trial
it's amazing so this is something we're
very interested in understanding hearing
using in our own evaluations
Leora Horowitz who was at Yale and now
has been at NYU for some time I trained
came up with her and in sort of a
similar group has been testing this
usually randomized controlled trials at
NYU for the last period of time when
they try and say how can we improve
smoking cessation how can we address
gaps in recommended preventive care or
increasing the number of people that
were monitoring for wellness they study
these heavily and then they they
basically make decisions about the
research that's done from the from the
randomized trials or other trials that
they do on what's what's really
effective or not and so it's a wonderful
idea and there's so much work in getting
that data ready and running those trials
that it's just a wonderful way to start
bringing more data if you're more
quantitative like you're more into omics
type data I'll give you an example for
predicting who will have a heart attack
or stroke in the next year five years or
ten years both proteins and genetic risk
is incredibly important part of that but
we don't use it to predict risk instead
we sort of treat people without knowing
that with sort of average risk by
populations and so one way you could do
this is say when I add in that other
risk indices to two patients do I see
better outcomes
okay wait now prevent more people from
having a heart attack or stroke and
that's right now we should be doing that
but we need to work on that we have a
learning health system here through a
k-12 that G Murray geese and here and at
Kaiser Luci Sabbats Co P I we have Dana
Womack is our fellow here if you know
her and there's this is a great
initiative because there's so many local
institutions participating on it she's
been looking at workplace strain and
potential for error and harm to patients
when nurses on the floor get overwhelmed
with the number of things that are given
to them and their attention is drawn in
different ways and how do you address
that so a wonderful thing that really is
very the institution's very interested
in that and she basically uses unusual
data types that you know like using the
the automated sort of communication
tools the Viserys and then looking at
the information from the EHRs for how
many people are delivering medications
over time and who's delivering the
medication to understand potential
outcomes like unplanned overtime and
stress and strain reported by the nurses
so Michelle your slides
I apologize Michelle also you bar who
you may know here also looks at audit
log information to understand how people
how we could improve our use of the EHR
in general and specifically for
scheduling in certain patients or the
patterns of use and so I had a version
with your slides I did I apologize that
they worked in here but sort of amazing
stuff there so what can you do now you
all are you know interested at least in
informatics because you're here so one
is this k12 has people always coming
applications you could sort of apply if
you really want to get in the field and
work with an institution on that oak
tree is a key site and they recently
redid their webpage
and it's great you can now find things
much more easily and you could talk to
rob shop here it is here ahead of the
RDW and the clinical research
informatics group they're about sort of
what you need there are a number of
services that are available to trainees
and you can really use those effectively
like I said there's a number 2025
efforts not just in research but
actually there's a whole effort in
digital healthcare that's ongoing and
the institution is really going to that
lots of opportunities there there's a
team that does transforms epic called
epic for research team I'll show you a
little bit about them you can contact
them and something if you're interested
in using epic for your research that's
much more like I'm trying to change epic
or interface you'd put a fire
application and epic you've talked to
them so the epic for research team they
do a lot of best practices for
recruiting they send my chart messages
the portal based messages for recruiting
it's Rachel and Deana currently they do
the fire app implementations so if you
have a fire app you think will transform
the world then you can talk to them and
we can sort of work together to try and
figure out a pathway to get that in and
they also do research orders there's
3,000 research orders monthly so they
those are all done in epic for the most
part overall so finally and then I'm
going to open it up for your questions
or thoughts Steve kesakhian here and
Bill's on the committee and probably
several other youth are we're having an
event a thon which is the sort of in the
MIT hacking medicine approach where
basically over a weekend May 1st through
3rd you get together and you try and
solve problems in healthcare they're
focusing on sort of you know device
medtech and then digital health and the
health IT although I think you're
refining the use cases so there'll be an
update on this if you're interested in
that save that date there'll be ways
that you can get involved in that a fun
weekend from everything that I
I've heard so that's it now let's open
it up and get your real questions out
overall so thank you so much no
questions
so my research search interest
learning health system Haitian based
data and data integration so could you
talk about I noticed in your talk you
were doing looking at social
determinants of health using NLP is
there some reason to use that instead
what kinds of things are you looking at
for the social determinants of health
using NLP so you're when you say
location-based you mean like Geographic
or aerial measures yeah so there is good
so if we think about using models based
on census tract or zip code for
individual for for an individual
individual prediction that it is those
are country you know if you just use zip
code and you know they have like percent
of people in poverty or if it's an
educational attainment in that zip code
those are really useful to predict even
at the individual level
a person's course in a particular
treatment or their additional needs so
that's really valuable work and in fact
you can use that data lots of different
ways one of the ami best paper student
best papers use GIS to like do a whole
bunch of different comparisons to
identify groups that they might want to
focus in on in the Philadelphia area and
it was amazing so good you can combine
all these different data together for a
number of the efforts that we have we
want to know that this person in front
of us actually has this issue so it's
really different by if you're tailoring
an intervention and there's a study that
just came out out of Boston where they
basically had patients with diabetes
they asked us suite of questions which
is sort of the way this is being done
about their you know food insecurity do
you have a housing insecurity these
kinds of social determinants and then if
they had food insecurity they helped
connect them to resources and they also
changed they help them find a diet that
could work given their lack of ability
to get expensive food which often the
healthier options can be more expensive
so they actually tailor
Roch there and they showed that people
had some better outcomes especially
about hypoglycemia so I had a patient
like this in my clinical practice and he
had a was on insulin a would run out of
food each month and he would have
hypoglycemia and he'd fall and he
actually didn't have a house here his
housing insecurity lived in a band and
so we had to work through a bunch of
these issues and so sometimes you need
the geographic is good enough because
you can sort of plan resources and make
predictions but sometimes you need the
individual and for our studies we're
really trying to understand what was
happening with individuals over time
especially as some groups from
Vanderbilt found out that housing
insecurity really varies over time for
some people that they actually get some
more stable housing or you can see this
and so using the EHR you can actually
see does is that status changing over
time as people get access to resources
so so you could really do a longitudinal
look and see the outcomes of your effort
so just a different place in the
research arena other other questions
Chris Chris has a question oh go ahead
no you're right there the Chris can be
next yeah
my question was
yeah that's a good question because I
just present the f measure here so it
depends on the problem so let's go to
chest x-rays so the vast majority of
chest x-rays are negative so they're
taken routinely they don't show anything
it's just sort of normal overall and so
I believe in that study they're much
more false positives overall but
including for reading as well so so it's
so overall but it really depends on sort
of your underlying prevalence and the
problem that you're trying to address in
this one it's a little bit complicated
because they also there's also
misdiagnosis so they say they have a
pneumonia but really they had a fusion
or something like that so they actually
looked at eight different diagnoses
overall but it really depends on sort of
the underlying prevalence organization
but it's sort of amazing given that
because it's easier for radiologists
actually to know a little bit about the
clinical case and have a prior
probability and then make a more
accurate diagnosis whereas the machine
learning techniques sort of do that but
not they mostly focus on the images sort
of the actually processing the images
but that's a big issue actually because
I didn't say this but I almost always
say this an algorithm that works at one
setting you cannot assume it's gonna
work at the new setting in part because
of those differences not just in the
data but the underlying patient
populations as well and we have seen
that in some of these so would we get a
new request for machine learning then we
have to revalidate it basically every
time still so the question I was going
to ask is about the patient-centered
outcomes work at OHSU that you were
mentioning yeah might go forward and and
I was curious given that there's such a
plethora of patient-centered outcomes
that we should use is there any sense of
looking at what patient-centered
outcomes Oh a chess you Reacher's
researchers have already studied and
published on to maybe prioritize getting
some of those yeah
patient measures
to the literature so that people are
doing follow-up studies or different
studies comparative studies that we're
already focusing on the ones we've
already tried to do before using non
informatics methods yeah no that's a
good question so I would say a high
level of establishing a system to better
work on patient reported outcomes is as
follows so at OHSU we're actually taking
that approach so I'm doing a very much
inductive approach where we find use
cases where people are working on this
for example the spine Center has long
been collecting pain and function
reported outcomes they have developed
the system where actually people report
those and then they put them into some
kind of tool to then not epic really I
mean they put them into epic but to
manage and understand the data they have
to use these other tool sets and like
they're an easy group to prioritize
because they want to do this and study
it and improve it and there's there's a
balance in a way because we have I don't
know six or seven of those use cases we
were already collected but the validity
of the underlying patient reported
outcomes in studies is pretty variable
actually even in the ones done here and
so we have to balance the sort of
feasibility pragmatic approach with sort
of what what is the most valid
scientifically acceptable way of doing
this but in general I would usually push
from the socio-technical point of view
to say if somebody's really interested
in monitoring and measuring and has
already been doing research in it it's
so much easier to make a difference
because they're gonna drive that human
element and get people to do it because
you could build all the patient reported
outcomes infrastructure in the world and
send them out to patients without sort
of a team focused on getting that data
and using it it just isn't likely to be
successful and but we are looking at
ways to make it easier we're gonna send
many more requests out to
patience as they sign up to enter this
data before they come in in a structured
format so we are exploring different
ways to get at it and there's a whole
art and science in that sort of area as
well and so I think we need to study
that as well yeah oh no date done yeah
whoever's next please sorry
yeah so we do have funding under the
research informatics it is not enough to
transform it's the the entire endeavor
so I think that's a good question
actually to to think about which is
where will the funding come from to do
this and actually in my examples I try
and focus a little bit on as we deliver
care what do we what should we be
looking at to sort of the health system
should invest in because it's incredibly
important and there is some interest in
that so I anticipate that there will be
some ongoing funding for evaluation
related to the health system components
we're gonna build more infrastructure
and so you know a really long term
outcome for us is more research funding
could be from industry I mean industry
is very interested in building tools and
applications that can be useful to
people and I you know there's some work
already done in that for phenotype bill
and Aaron have been working with precise
computable phenotype work for what is it
porphyria acute intermittent porphyria
so you know and that company has a drug
to treat that so and that's good you
know because it's something that's under
diagnosed so I think it will be from a
variety of sources NIH is very
interested in this so I think from a
research perspective it's a clear
opportunity for us at a loss if we don't
do it so that's that's one win place the
total amount of funding I don't know but
I think that we'll have enough to really
get some use cases and improve the tools
that we have for sure okay who's next
this may be this guy and then you could
say your name so I don't have to call
you this person yes so I shouldn't use
guys so my apologies this person so a
bit of a selfish question but relative
you mentioned a moment ago about the
socio-technical connection of you have
these clinical practice guidelines you
have patient reported outcomes the other
half of that circle of really going from
having the knowledge and using it how
much of the focus is on
now this kind of the socio-technical
implementation piece yeah i'm focused
more on doing better at capturing and
making sense of the data because i know
there are so many problems there however
which issue has some amazing strengths
because we produce the evidence we sort
of help people write guidelines through
the EPC or at least get the systematic
reviews out that then are used for the
guidelines there's a bunch of effort
going on that regards and in our new
high blood pressure grant we're like
plugged into that so if you think about
a guideline it is not computable it is
all narrative recommendations how do you
go from there to make it logic and the
sort of underlying data elements that
would drive implementation of those that
is happening and we are through that
process using something called CPG on
fire clinical practice guidelines on
fire to go all the way down that path it
is weird it is not many of the
recommendations cannot be put in and so
we've sort of ended up for hypertension
there's eight guidelines we have 71
recommendations and we're like oh god we
can't do all of those so there's really
a prioritization process for what
knowledge should be transferred and so
one of the things that we look at is
where's there's a real gap we know we're
not doing well at this we could actually
measure it it's feasible and we try and
prioritize those so there's effort in
that I think there's ongoing desire and
clinical transformation to do better at
getting knowledge into performance but
it's it's still it's still a gap and so
well it's a wonderful group CDC that's a
bunch of work in this and has had
funding in it in the past so that's an
unusual group that does focus on that
yeah so I'm interested in all the
existing connections with outside
databases that my related involvement in
social services or educational yeah
things like that I know that the funding
for researching that cut stuff is uses
yeah so the CDC as well is working on
that in a project called med morph that
is looking specifically at the public
health components the connections are
pretty rare as you know there and
there's a lot of reasons for that we
wrote a grant that was not funded to
basically enhance those connections
because in Oregon coordinated cordwood
coordinated care organizations that
serve the Medicaid population have a
community role that where they basically
need to work with those social service
agencies and they're still talking to
them about you know could we build
something that would be more health more
beneficial to get that data across there
is a program called the accountable
health communities that is tracking data
on social determinants and then sending
it to different sites including social
service agencies and there's navigators
that can help people with that and then
there's a program called Unitas that is
a fire based application that is being
looked at and I haven't heard more about
it recently to connect these as well I
don't know it's overall functionality if
it's really well integrated or not into
the agencies but that's improved
dramatically over the last ten years so
I bet in the next five we're gonna see a
much better infrastructure and I think
it's a great area to work because the
mission of people in it is so wonderful
trying to leverage provide these
incredibly important services and
they've historically been left out of
this information loop just you know
paper forms largely so I think it's a
good area but Med Wharf
is directly looking at this and may be a
good one to follow maybe a bit of an
ignorant question but yeah okay so thank
you for asking that question it's about
like how much are corporations doing
this industry doing this versus how much
is actually coming from on the ground
from health systems from academics this
is a huge issue for us actually right
now and and the reason is mult so
there's a ton being done in industry and
I don't know if you've seen recently but
Google's like buying tons of medical
hundreds of billions of medical records
like from Cerner and other people and
they've they actually had a study where
they work with UCSF and University of
Chicago to predict big mortality and
hospitalization in the future and then
somebody sued them because they had
actually their GPS location data and it
could actually from that data RIA denta
fie them so I think there's a ton of
venture capital money going into this
there's a ton of hype there's a ton of
money and lots of places are our groups
are focusing on this what they lack is
really good insight into the issues of
the data that I described but also the
way the system works like it's really
hard to understand the way the
healthcare system works or doesn't work
and the sort of pitfalls they might have
and the way you know all this
complication of around the medical
language and how it's coded and so I see
an incredibly important role for health
systems and innovators within them or
academia to work on this that being said
I mean most of the money I think is is
going to industry we just have to figure
out a way to collaborate to make to help
them have the best outcomes because
they're going to be more selling
directly to patients like patient-facing
tools and applications
and we need to help make sure those are
safe FDA is going to regulate more of
those I'm not sure how I feel about the
scope of the regulations that's still in
draft but you know I think it's an open
question it's probably the question of
the decade to be honest for me you know
one more should be somebody texted me
you had mentioned something about
randomized quality improvement projects
yeah what I was wondering to what extent
the providers like the nurses and staff
that are implementing this how much
they're aware of what's being done with
the EHR recommendations over time
whether or not they're blind to it or
they know this is happening and they're
they've bought into it they're they're
proponents of this yeah that's a good
question
I've done a pragmatic clinical trial a
couple of them actually and for most of
them we consent care team members that
the providers the clinicians the other
team members because they have to be
aware and blinding is a huge issue so if
you think about there's three
opportunities blind the person who sees
it this study investigators not
including the analysts and the analysts
and we can only blind to the analyst
because they're seeing something
different but this clustering this is an
art in pragmatic trials and it is a
challenge so I think that's a very good
question because there's some bias right
I mean you're being shown something
different however you can really limit
that bias in a bunch of different ways
I think ethically who you should consent
is really important and you know in
general I think it's we've mostly
focused if we're gonna present something
potentially different to you even if
it's just information we try and consent
you under our studies because I think
you know one we need to know your
perspective on it whether you've noticed
it or things like that but also you know
ethically we need their buy-in all right
thank you